حيوانات حيوانات بين الناس وفي الغابات
تعطي جمالا للحياه يا ل جمال الكائنات
تعطي جمالا للحياه يا ل جمال
الكائنات ثعلب واكن ثعلوب خداع دوما لعوب
ثعلب واكن ثعلوب خداع دوما ولعوب مكار لقب
المشهور في الغالب ارجع مغلوب في الغالب
ارجع
مغلوب في عز امشي وشهامه نمر جسمي فيه
ضخامه في عز امشي وشهامه نمر جسمي فيه
ضخامه كالقطه لكني اكبر وخطوط السوداء
علامه وخطوط السوداء
علامه براسي قرن ميزني ضخم ما اكبر وزني
براسي قرن ميزني ضخم ما اكبر وزني لوني
رمادي وجميل سموني وحيد القرن سموني وحيد
القرن حيوانات حيوانات بين الناس وفي
الغابات تعطي جمالا للحياه يا لا جمال
الكائنات لي جلد ضخم وحراش سباح ايضا انا
زاحف لي جلد ضخم وحراش سباح ايضا انا زاحف
انظر ما اكبر فكي تمساح لي دمع زائف تمساح
لي دمع
زائف طيبه القلب ووديعه فاتنه المظهر
ومطيعه طيبه القلب ووديعه فاتنه المظهر
ومطيعه لي قرنان اسمى غزاله بالجري انا جد
سريعه بالجري انا جد
سريعه انا فرس النهر الم تعلم بين
الحيوانات الاضخم انا فرس النهر الم تعلم
بين الحيوانات الاضخم في لابسي اقضي وقتي
او في النهر انا استحم او في النهر انا
استحم حيوانات حيوانات بين الناس وفي
الغابات تطي جمالا للحياه يا لا جمال
[موسيقى]
الكائنات